[Music]
hello guys again
um
i'm serious i'm gonna talk uh today
also about the games of the week
um and i for this for a game actually
because i prepared only one
but it was nevertheless extremely
interesting and
complicated and there was lots of going
on so i think
even one hour wouldn't be enough for his
life for this game
but anyway so
i'm going to talk about game versus ray
of ray robson versus
hikaru nakamura from u.s championships
2020
and i in this game
i think just kind of like
as an introduction i can say that i
think now hikaru nakamura tried
to win too hard because of his opening
choice
and his big ambition to win it
especially that he looked at
he didn't play his best just during this
tournament
and however you know shows great
fighting spirit of his
and the mistakes that that happened in
the game
were probably result again of the rapid
chance not not because of skills of
players which are extremely high for
you know for both of them obviously so
uh
let's let's see what happened in this
game why it's so interesting in my
opinion
so e4 c5 and again usually hikaru
chooses
either berlin or like some maybe c6 g6
and stuff like that especially i think
he chose against jeffrey g6 d6
against ray robson he decided to play
something uh
he i didn't see actually ever him ever
playing
uh you know paulson or khan
sicilian uh so cd4 uh 94
a6 i don't think i've ever seen ricardo
playing this opening
bishop d3 one of the most natural moves
knight f6 uh sure castle queen c7
queen e2 d6 is all fury c4
and here we got uh the marti pawn
structure
which is
considered as a source of white's
advantage in many many of the positions
and uh it is also
and usually in this type of position
where i should say white
tries to play a rather positional chess
than
uh dynamic so no no
no dynamic like aggressive attack the
king and so on
however it is still also possible to
basically develop very strong
attack on black's king here as well
depending probably depends on the mood
of the player and who's playing and so
on
uh so right now as far as i know the
most popular move is g6 and this is the
move i employed myself
as a kid when i was you know like um
maybe 11 12 years old i remember playing
playing
g6 like many times as black and uh
it's quite interesting you develop
bishop to g7 try to play knight c6 then
maybe 9795
for instance after 96 bishop uh g7
knight the three knight c6
sometimes the idea is to play knight d7
knight e5 uh short castle maybe we won't
play b6 bishop b7 sort of like a
hedgehog
but with bishop on g7 which is
considered as
some small improvement however it can
lead this d6 pawn also vulnerable so it
all depends
hikaru decided to play knight bd7 this
is a little bit surprising probably it's
just some sideline
that i wasn't really familiar with
however it's pretty
tricky move because idea is
to play move knight e5 right now and the
the postponing the the development of
bishop from
f8 still you can go
through g6 if you want to but you start
moving
with this move to prepare maybe knight
e5
and in my opinion the best move right
now for wise would be to play f4
simply prevent knight d5 and then after
bishop e7 let's say knight c3
shortcast will be sorry king h1 b6
bishop d2 play such position
and as i said it is possible to
attack to develop the attack on the
on black king in this type of positions
even though it's maybe not necessary
however if you play f4 already
it means that you are committing
yourself to very dynamic and aggressive
play you don't have time anymore to play
uh let's say super positional and uh you
know like for instance
typical uh i'll just quickly show after
g6 typical let's say
play it could have happened for instance
lc3 united three you see there is no
attack here anymore let's say knight uh
c6 let's say bishop f4 short castle
maybe rook ac1
knight d7 rfd1 knight d5 for instance
this type of play is very positional
there is of course
white doesn't create any attack and
tries to prove uh
advantage with more strategic or more
calm measures
on the other hand if as happened or in
the game like bd7 if you play right now
f4
you are basic you don't you're basically
committing yourself to uh
immediate uh let's say dynamic play and
probably this is what he
was aiming for he wanted to he wanted
a game full of fight and full of life
instead of just positional
you know battle he went uh is what i'm
understanding at least
he wanted to get something playable and
very very sharp
and especially with with his preparation
he
uh definitely would have had good two
good chances here
and actually knight bd7 uh
actually done his job because after f4
it it didn't happen in the game but like
you would
basically lead to a similar position as
in the game but with the knight and
bishop on the board
uh knight c3 is what the ray played and
this is in my opinion inaccuracy
because after 95 black manages to
trade bishop for for the night and the
winning pair of bishops simplify the
position a little bit and
hedgehog with more the more traded
pieces the more the trade pieces the the
more bearable hedgehog structure is or
more what's this structure is
so a four knight xd and anyway right now
you have to play f4 like you don't
you cannot play just positional chess
because then you have no advantage
because already
black would trade one pair of pieces and
then fully
develop you know the rest and if you
play positional you will not have you
know
you're likely not going to get anything
so
f4 knight takes d3 queen takes d3 was
logical bishop b7
b3 uh also is a logical way of
developing the bishop
bishop goes to b2 and the pawn b3
supports c4
uh pawn bishop b2 b6 rook e1
bishop b7 king h1 yes and all those
moves were pretty natural pretty
standard uh
bishop uh white bishop would be zero to
b7
white white also to b2 uh king h1 also
the logical rooks are perfectly placed
only one f1
and the question is i think this is the
critical position uh
the question is right now what to do
next with black because it's
you know how to place the rooks how to
maybe place the you know
how to solve the problem of potential
aggression on the
[Music]
king side and it is not entirely
clear at least at first sight how to
solve those let's say problems
do the question is whether why wants to
play e5 or maybe white doesn't want to
play e5
and maybe y wants to play f5
y has lots of ideas here and as black it
is not
easy to let's say to
unders not understand like you know just
to pick the right plan
to basically deal with all those ideas
wise at the same time
however there is such a plan and
probably there are more than
probabilities more than one
however the one i like specifically is
to play simple move rook fe-8
the idea is to play with bishop f8 next
and uh
to maintain the sort of control over the
e6
square in case of f5 always there will
be possibility to play with bishop f8 or
something like this and to cover the
[Music]
e6 pawn also it prepares action in this
it prepares simply for action center so
let's say if i analyze some move like
rook e3
bishop f8 and for instance after f5
we can black and play suddenly d5
and what happens is that what position
opens
it draw and the black is actually ready
for such a
active play in the center unlike white
after f takes e6 for instance he takes
e4 analyze knight x if knight takes e4
simply bishop takes e4 knight takes e4
pawn takes
queen takes it's all pretty much forced
and here we got the position with
uh queen and pawn for two rooks and i
don't think black has any any problems
here after the queen of friends say king
g8
everything is well defended i don't see
any problems here for uh
for black i think that is just doing
quite okay here
so uh this was one of the possibilities
to how to react to let's say this uh
aggressive setup by white uh let me show
under variation and say rookie free
bishop f8
um if here white place decides to play
e5 which is also very you know logical
this doesn't uh bring much to to white
because after detached c4
b takes c4 knight g4 white's pawn
structure is pretty much messed up and
actually white pieces are running into
some attack of
you know look on e3 being under attack
upon only five is hanging as well
let's say it takes takes i don't
actually see what uh
white is doing next i think after
h3 just g6 it's completely okay for
black as well
so uh and only five po the opponent e5
simply falls
the bishop on b7 is on the perfect
diagonal on the iron white bishop on b2
is completely stuck behind his own pawn
on e5
and knights same time so it doesn't go
doesn't it anywhere
uh if rook fe-8 let's say queen g3 is
also very natural move to you know bring
the queen put some pressure on this
g7 pawn and on this diagonal some ideas
might not be 95 or something
like this knight f5 simply bishop the
way it solves all the problems i don't
see any problems here
uh for for black like
if let's say e5 you can just play at h5
with queen g4
just g6
don't see what next uh what what next
worldwide this is
doing next for instance bishop e4 is not
possible okay if bishop e4 i can always
at least take
if i see any any problems with this um
you know knight on e4 but yeah so this
is very logical
and i'm not sure right now but i think
actually f5 will be just winning a piece
or like an exchange
because after this this there will be a
fork
uh zero current calculation i'm not
exactly sure right now but i think it
should work for
uh maybe actually not 96 it's actually
possible so maybe this is not
[Music]
maybe this is not actually that great
however you know uh
if i don't play five i can play for
instance if i want to be super solid
i can play rook f8 uh rook 88 i mean or
maybe just bishop g7 or maybe bring the
knight to f5 also as possible i don't
see any problems here for black
whatsoever there's
a number of moves that are you know
holding the equality
and if if this suddenly somehow works uh
also this could be possibility however
i'm not sure but
just you just make a few more moves i
don't think even in this position black
has too much
too many worries maybe it's slightly
worse because down
black is down the pawn but such activity
should grant a draw eventually
so this was the correct way to play here
as black instead of hit car play with
knight d7 which is all typical let's say
hedgehog move you want to bring this
knight to c5 play bishop f6 to
neutralize this bishop from b2
and also you run away from any ideas
with connective e5 while playing e5
but on the from the other on the other
hand
it allows move f5 which
right now it's much more
difficult to fail to face pretty much
because
if if this rule goes on e8
like here if f5 you can always play
bishop of eight you just keep the pawn
structure the same
and after f5 right now you
you are it's not easy to guard your e6
pawn
if you if you don't want you never want
sorry black never wants to play move
like e5
uh because you know first of all just
weakens d5 square
on the other on top of that there is
possibility to play f6 knight f4 and
the knight five with very strong
initiative even if it's not possible
like e5 i can play just repeat my knight
and i see 293 knight d5
or i can maybe consider as i said move
f6 and then knight f5
so there are lots of ideas here for what
i can do and um
i'm not exactly i don't really really
like this position for black
so uh the one the most natural move
obviously for black is to play knight c5
and pro
this is what hikaru played very quickly
if i i'm not mistaken from i remember
for when i looked at the you know like
the
online uh online how much he spent
how much people play time the players
spend here on the move
so knight c5 happened but this is uh
this
logical move this natural move is
actually a losing one
and how can this such move be losing one
right uh seemingly
like it shouldn't be a thing should be
quite okay still for black
uh but it's not it's simply it's not
good
so what is the only move for black what
would black should do if not knight c5
and the
answer is bishop h4 the point is
black simply has to cover g3 square from
white queen
that because if the white queen gets
there to this
square on g3 suddenly
this diagonal is
you know there all could be all sort of
ideas of tactical ideas on this diagonal
because of
uh queen g3 bishop b2
they work perfectly together with some
mates id making ideas on g7
knights can let's say knight b5 knight
d5 or something like this
uh would be you know extremely difficult
to face for
uh for black therefore you have to stop
this
if the bishop h4 first cover g3 square
and if the rook moves you just go r8
try to again hold the pawn structure the
same still
deposit i believe that this position is
extremely dangerous for black and i
don't think
that this pushes you know maybe
i will say this maybe the best
absolutely best play for black
it should be it is still okay however
it is not easy to play uh all those only
moves or like you know such difficult
deep moves like bishop h4 isn't easy
move to play at all
after rook h3 i've uh queen d8
i thought was also like
you know okay for black but again it's
not an easy move to play
like there are some f6 they have to be
considered like all
kind of all sort of ideas are there for
for white
and it is seeming it's much easier to
place position with wider and
rather than with black so i'm not sure
whether
all this was uh really optimal for
hikaru to play
but yeah bishop h4 was bishop h4 here
was still maintaining the relatively the
balance
on the other hand here uh hikaru played
moonlight c5
after queen g3 was very very strong move
as i said queen belongs there bishop f6
right if e5 right now again this
possibility plays
9293 and so on but there's also much
something much stronger like f6 and this
knight f5 this looks simply overwhelming
um this position looks just over me
design of the
knight on the f5 is extremely powerful
the white is white has very strong
attack and great perspective
great attacking perspectives on the on
the king's side
so uh bishop f6 happened in the game
and right now uh ray uh known for his
tactical wizardry
uh played very strong and
[Music]
how to put it entertaining
move knight d to b5 and essentially uh
widely sacrificing two knights in order
to open this bishop from b2
considering this queen on c7 is actually
possible to attack what the note
is possible to be attacked by a white uh
knights
so eight xb5 and now knight d5 of course
would be a big mistake playing and 95
because after let's say queen e7
the bishop on his f6 will be protected
so we need to attack twice
on on f6 with the both knight and and
bishop so uh i know i
maybe he carves solid or maybe he misses
i have no idea uh
it takes d5 bishop takes f6 g6
and in this position
um it seems like it is nearly a mate
because like you know bishop on f6 all
dark squares are extremely
sorry i should put green uh all the
squares are extremely weak like queen h4
queen h6 seems like you know just game
over it should be just mating
right um so here and here is the thing
you don't as white you don't have to
actually
really rush with this this bishop on f6
uh and such you know weak king that
black has
gives white some time to basically play
actually
a move that improves the position
slightly
and
stabilizes the center and on top of that
uh you know keeps all the ideas in hand
and this move is to simply play it takes
d5
this was simply winning like it takes d5
and ions to be honest it's hard to come
up with the
ideas here for for black from let's say
strategical point of view so it's
a strategic point of view bishop on b7
is completely awful
it's busted like it's not doing anything
there the lc5
is uh you know well placed but like it
doesn't do anything on the king side as
well so probably has to go back or
something id7 right
uh i'll auto discuss the line in the
moment
rooks are very weak i mean like more
like glue on the face is not doing
anything or 198 also
is not doing much attacks on a2 but like
it's irrelevant poem considering that
there is a checkmate nearly on the
on the king side and queen 7 is also
very passive
so all black pieces are misplaced so
if black tries to sort of kick out this
bishop from f6
right now y can play either rookie seven
or maybe
also take and then after this rook b7
this idea is simply overwhelming
um but yeah rookie seven at first
seems like just is just crashing uh and
then after
g6 and uh you know it should be should
be somehow winning
should be yeah this must win also fg6 if
you start with this
if you like f6 you can just play this
and of course you have to move queen c3
also it's very nice tactical idea
you take the queen on f6 and as i said
this bishop is never joining the defense
and white simply or simply is winning
so uh this movie takes d5 was simply
finishing the game like move number 21
would be just pretty much game over in a
few moves
however jeffrey sorry ray play move
queen h4
and this seemingly making move is
actually
spoiling all the advantage it's not like
it's spoiling you know like some part of
advantage it's probably
all the advantage it's
like i found it extremely instructive
because
like seemingly queen h4 you just want to
checkmate right like queen h6 just
coming in and that's it and
the thing is it's not so easy after 97
suddenly knight is going to kick this
bishop out
you have to move your bishop somewhere
and you can move let's say wherever
because if let's say go on this diagonal
i'm gonna just cover everything
and uh i'll be doing very well heroes
black probably i would just write an
extra
piece and win the game so we have to
play
bishop e7 here after bishop b7 suddenly
again f6
i this is what hikaru played so it was
great defense here by hikaru
who covered suddenly all the dark
squares
and make schmidt made sure that he's on
getting checkmated here
and black black is back in the game here
after f6
right 97 f6 black is back in the game
back in business
so this was a big mistake here by ray a
queen h4
uh and after bishop b7 f6 black is
black is doing suddenly okay so in the
game happen if take g6 h6 g6
bishop takes f8 you have to capture the
rook because otherwise how to continue
the attack if you don't take the
the rook you outplay just rook f7 or
something and
then knight d5 and i'll just retain
extra piece and then
probably with another one this is bishop
on e7 being you know
misplaced so you have to basically take
the rook
takes and it takes d5
and right now the phrase of course to
play rookie seven seemingly white is
still winning
because rookie seven is uh fret
and uh how you're gonna defend from this
queen d8 super passive allows rookie six
for instance
but here ricardo played very strong move
knight d5
and the idea is that poland f6 doesn't
quite matter what matters is that
[Music]
black covers all the you know doesn't
allow rookie seven
and puts the knight to the center where
it keeps together
in a poll on g6 also attacks on the
queen side the pawn on c4
so uh it is uh the knight simply belongs
there and
solves all the you know black blacks
problems here
so rook f6 happened seemingly white is
doing well
uh and indeed white is still somewhat
better what is still
slightly slightly better i'm not sure
how big of an advantage it is still
but uh it is still somewhat better here
for
white from let's say practical point of
view only um
the reason for this is that bishop
nissan is still not participating in the
game
and there are two extra two pawns for
this um
uh why why has rook and two pawns not
like one pound or something
there are two pawns uh for two pieces
so rook takes a fade queen takes the
fade and yeah here
basically the dust settled like the you
know all the complications
finished and we need to
understand right when i was looking this
position first
i was thinking that white is still
much better like there is still bishop
on b7 misplaced
um black king is also very exposed there
are two
pawns not only five is well placed true
but like
there's loads of pawns still and i don't
uh and i didn't think that
black should be you know should have
enough defensive resources here
on the other hand it's hard to make a
progress here that's why
too because poland c4 is
let's say maybe potentially weak if
let's say bc bc happens
i mean b takes it will be take c4 not
only 5
really keeps everything together like
it's like a glue like it just
keeps all the position together like
keeps pawn on g6 defended and
uh closes the e file white rook can be
activated
so easily and as we all know uh
the rook is especially well
or well placed or the most functional
it's on the open file right now
the only open file f file is actually
covered uh
controlled by white sorry by black queen
on f8
and the other e file uh is blocked by
the knight on e5
so the white rock is also not really
doing much
so uh ray right now playing with king g1
is very logical
because he tried he tries to play move
rook f1 and try to you know improve the
rook and
try to create some attack on the on the
king side
bc bc logical capture capture
bishop a6 uh also very logical finally
this bishop must be improved
if this bishop is not improved like
black can simply just resign because
uh this bishop will be not doing no
paris will not be participating in the
game so this bishop must be must join
the game and here uh right playing with
e4
we're logical defining this uh c4 pawn
and here was the critical position again
another
another quick operation in this game
it's not not the last one so rook e4
and in this position black has some
choice because the thing is that on c4
right now white is well guarded
the problem is the question is how to
proceed as
black because b5 move is unlikely gonna
i'm gonna be working because i can play
maybe move like c5
and if you play c uh yeah cb of course i
don't want because
uh bishop takes b5 opens the bishop
also there is more like f4 possible
so there is some there are some issues
with b5
uh seemingly all pieces
apart from the queen on the f8 uh black
queen of eight are
well placed they are active 95 is of
course amazing which almost puts
pressure on c4 pawn
queen of eight though does only performs
only defensive tasks
so makes sense to activate it somehow
and uh he currently moved queen f5
and this move seemingly is logical
because we want to improve it
and you know maybe create some threads
of bishop take c4 who takes it for queen
b1 check and then look for some
perpetual or maybe some attack on the
on white screen on white's king however
it allows move queen d8
and
you know and where at least white can
make a draw if right already once
because of the perpetual or you know
some
yeah yeah because of the perpetual or at
least you know take a test on pawn on b6
or something uh
and uh it depends on what how white uh
sorry
how black reacts but but anyway queen d8
gives some
you know checks from behind and they are
not easy to
be dealt with
so uh i try to come up with some other
solution and
actually i realize the queen on the fade
in this position is well placed because
it guards
everything because the six point while
this d6 punk
cards e5 knight so and the e5 knight
cards g6 pawn so
basically queen of vet is part of a very
important um
let's say set up on the king sorry king
side
uh where it everything is well protected
and well defended
so right now uh black played uh queen f5
but this was not maybe not the best move
instead black would have played bishop
c8
and the to the very important thing is
to map
into to understand is that a bishop on
a6 is
well placed but is not the best square
for the
for the bishop if this bishop could be
brought to f5
it performs also defensive tests on the
king side
and challenges white rook
and i think position will be totally
unclear like if the bishop has to f5
and i don't know what exactly what is
doing next
unless i'm rugged f4 queen e8 for
instance h3 bishop f5
i know king h2k7 like okay some random
moves that gets freaking h2o but i also
play like
bishop h5 king g7 i don't know what is
what exactly why it's planned
i'm not sure what black's plan is but
like uh
for now but i would consider at least at
some point uh moves like knight d3
not yet because rook takes the f5 will
win the game but maybe you know
i don't know queen f2 for instance
knight d3 definitely has to be
considered
at some point knight d3 could be
basically also another possibility is to
you know
bring the king forward let's say queen
of seven queen f6 you never know right
now whether
uh trading queens will be in front why
is fair or black's favor
it calculation is pretty much totally
unclear and anything can happen
like the i mean yeah anything can happen
in this position
so um
bishop c8 i think this was one of one
very strong move and very instructive
moves because uh
bishop on a6 is well placed attack c4
pawn but it could be even better place
on f5
where regards everything um
yeah so high play queen five which is my
in my opinion not the best move
uh right now i thought rook f4 was uh
you know a little bit more accurate
however after g5
we would end up in such end game which
likely
would be a drawn end game uh but
still i think it is a little bit easier
to play this end game with white let's
say king f2
because white has two past pawns
connected
and it should be way easier to push them
forward rather than black spawns
also black spawns are still far away
and uh it is not entirely trivial how to
how that is going to push them forward
however you know to push white spawn is
not a big philosophy just h
g4 h4 h4 g4 h5 king g3 and
and you know keep them keep them rolling
right
so uh i think this this would be there
will be some chances for white some
slight advantage
however correct play probably black
black can equalize here
um yeah so rook four was probably the
best chance
on the other hand queen dave the move
that the right place is the most natural
move of course is a good move is a very
natural move
uh but after let's say queen f8 or
something like or let's say king g7
actually uh i would wouldn't it was not
in the game after queen 17 g8
i don't see actually a follow-up because
regular only four is hanging
maybe ray was already kind of like quite
happy with the draw i know
this time situation on the clock but
[Music]
maybe maybe ray was kind of happy with
that draw here or something that's why
he played queen d8
and ruka four stereochemism calculation
of uh
like after once again queen of five
rupee four request call
of queen b first of all juventus be
calculated queen wants to be calculated
and of course queen bond just rook f1
but like there is there is more
calculation to you know
uh to to be done however quindy is just
very easy move to be played in time
let's say temporary time pressure
because you're just
throwing a check so but yeah it's also
very natural it's also pretty good
so uh queen of eight happened but ray
ryan didn't want to make a draw he
played queen c7
he went here he kept his queen acting
was it was correct
so uh right now
i don't know what
like in this position of course pawn c4
is well defended again
we hope c8 bishop the fight could be
considered still but it's not as good as
it was already
before because coin 7 is much more
active than it was
the same move earlier there are ideas of
rook h4 as well for white
it's not the same position
in this position g5 was played by hikaru
and probably in this position
i have this i'm probably i mean i don't
know
probably either hikaru panicked or
if he'd been planning he overestimated
his chances because
there is nothing that
let's say from if we look at this
position there is nothing that basically
sort of allows uh black to be playing
for a win
like if anyone who's on defensive side
is black wasn't under the defensive side
especially that white already declined
the draw of queen coming with queen to
c7
have declined repetition of moves with
queen c7
and pawn b6 is hanging in the future
pawnee 6 is also
kind of weak bishop on a6 is rather
misplaced
i mean it's well placed considering he's
on c4 but it's not as well placed as it
would be on a five square
um it's not easy to for uh for black to
make a movie here
uh so i don't know g5 was a terrible
move obviously
because uh i don't know where this phone
goes actually
uh the game happens just gh3 and
all those lines right now white's king
is safer than black's king because g5
just weakens the king
this is the big problem opponent g6 is
well guarded on g5 pawn is not
guarded at all so um
yeah like after in all those lines that
for instance
uh we'll see in a moment uh some lamp
example lines after uh what happened in
the game and
what could have happened in the game uh
where this g inclusion of g5 move
is not uh good for uh
for for black so the best move again was
just move queen f5
and try to you know activate the queen
if we cannot activate the
bishop from a6 right now just activate
the
queen and chase our opponent's rook and
try to you know
look for some activity and counter play
if rook h4 queen b1 of course
runs into millions of checks so rookie
one
probably has to be played but right now
after queen f4 we
are sort of guard at the sixth pawn
tactically because queen
693 would just win the queen and um
there are ideas of bishop take c4
obviously there are ideas of some queen
d4 checks and knight g4 maybe
at some point depends of course what
black is doing
uh because the new gay of course would
be a checkmate if we remove the knight
from e5 but like depends of course on
what black is doing
sorry what white is doing if rook f1
queen
d4 king h1 and queen takes c4
i don't see anything more than than a
perpetual check here
like again queen f8 seemingly would is
nearly winning but knight on e5 is so
powerful it covers f7 square and rook f7
is not
not possible so probably just why we
have to
push our news here just here
would we it would be just a draw
it will be just a draw in my opinion um
so yeah queen f5 was by far you know
the best move but this is what i'm
trying to kind of like
uh say like either he could have
panicked with g5
because he didn't like him after queen
five or
he overestimated his chances he didn't
want to make it through with queen f5
considering he carved his very strong
player and
he wanted to win this game considering
especially the tournament situation he
was like you know
like two or four two and a half some few
points back behind race so he want to
catch up with him probably
and he didn't want to make a draw but uh
i think that the risk that he took here
uh is a little bit excessive so g5
h3 queen f5 right now
but queen f5 right now runs into just
rookie one and the problem is
that in all those lines like here after
say minute queen f5
paulo g6 is you know like they say they
say this position with pawn on g5 and
upon h3
it can be the same exactly position uh
after black played
move g5 in this position is the drop of
pawn on g5
is simply winning for white and we'll
see why in this particular line
h3 in g5 which is rookie one if queen f4
is not sufficient because of rook f1
queen takes
queen d4 king queen x4 and queen d8 and
suddenly
because of the open sixth rank
a black white rook can get to f6 square
or like
or something like that and
suddenly there is mating net on on h6
and there is nothing white can
uh black and to stop that also queen 7
will get rid of the mating net as well
so the game is over just because it
points on g5
with pawn on g6 it wouldn't be possible
if pawn g5
black simply is lost
so uh so yeah
therefore this therefore this g5 move
was was a big mistake
and uh after rookie one white is already
winning here
bishop takes c4 queen takes d6 knight f7
trying to let's say make it position
solid
and here again uh but here we go again
this other critical position and here
right now
ray went wrong probably both players
were already like in deep time trouble
because
there is no way you could you can
understand you could or like justify
such
mistakes uh in let's say normal play
normal game however here probably is
move already 35 or e6
so both price players probably were in
deep time trouble
and um that's the again source of the
mistakes
from on on both on both ends so right
now
array play very let's say natural
quintex b6 but
it wasn't necessary to play queen b8 and
there is kind of like
you think about it's kind of logical but
like during the board during the game at
the board it doesn't seem logical why do
you give the check why not just take it
upon immediately
and different is very subtle the problem
is that after let's say queen b6
uh okay hikaru again probably panic with
g4 there's no reason to do this
but after let's say move bishop takes a2
d6 bishop e6
trying to locate the spawn d7 pawn queen
e3
bishop d7 black is doing quite okay
it's white is still obviously better
only white can win this their white can
only one can
only white can put some pressure here on
black
however it is very very close to uh
be drawn because of the blockade
and the kind of like lack of weaknesses
uh there are not many weaknesses and
black and if just black stays in place
i don't see how white makes too much of
a progress here
[Music]
still obviously white can try for many
moves but should be eventually a draw
the difference is that if we start first
with queen b8
king h7 queen b6 in the exact same line
d6 bishop b6 queen e3 bishop d7
we have not king on g8 as earlier but
the rhinox king king is on h7
and rook f1 right now simply ends the
game
and of course it's difficult to say
right now in the analysis and
criticizing gray or i mean i'm not
creating it
reader i'm just trying to analyze and be
objective here
so um the thing is that
it seems kind of like intuitive also if
you have enough time
to kick the skin a little bit out of the
center
and to make those the pawn uh
[Music]
i'm sorry the peace construction with
the knight and queen
a little bit more more vulnerable like
with kion g8 king also supports this
knight
if the king goes here both pieces are
not they're only for themselves they're
not even guarded by the king
additionally and therefore in this line
it
just shows however as i said it's easy
to
to you know to find it over the you know
at home
when you analyze the rather than during
the game uh but anyway queen b6 also
like
you know it's it's a mistake which
spoils you know big part of the
advantage
uh but uh hikaru probably also in time
travel
or panicked or something like this you
play g4 which was unnecessary
uh i kind of like i don't understand
this move but uh
yeah we'll probably just panic like
right now h3g4
uh ray played and this is winning of
course queen six was also winning
and try to trade the queens and there
are simply too many pawns and they are
very advanced
at this the last after this
you know the epon is very advanced and
pawn g4 will fall again
they fall as well um a pawn will also
probably move forward
very soon and their black pieces lack
coordination here black is simply
simply lost so uh but hcg4 also
obviously wins after h2
g4 queen d5 a4
one thing to note that white king is
extremely safe there is no way
black can do any danger to white king
because of the queen on b6 which guards
the diagonal
in all the possible ways no access to
white king whatsoever
why wants to simply push this pawn
forward and
the game is
pretty much decided already like with
some completely winning for white
uh also black pieces lack coordination
and this is not it's just just winning
for for
for white but here hikar played with
queen d7
and as you know as both players probably
were in deep time trouble this move was
quite tricky because it
attacks both pawns you have to decide
which one you defend which one you do
not defend
and
what you do it gives some choice a
little room for error right
so and here immediately by some reason
uh
ray play move queen g6 and this is very
um
inaccurate it's unnecessary check that
ray gave and uh there was no reason to
do this instead
for instance g5 was completely winning
uh
after queen a's f4 g6 and
you know just you know taking the knight
out of
f7 you know attacking
continue continuing the attack on uh on
black's king
and this will be just simply game over
um
after g5 let's say knight xg5 of course
queen g6 just
wins the game with the checkmate or at
least taking the knight
so g5 was was just the simplest other
winning way
for while it was to play a5 and after
quinton hd4 does rook e8
and then basically loads of checks
follow
and the pro this is a little bit more
complicated and probably unnecessary
if i have to if i would have to suggest
something
just g5 because just g6 just you know
it's very
very simple and natural to play such
moves however you know
it was time travel most likely replay
queen g6 king f8 and
right now queen f6 and suddenly after
queen f6
it was it just becomes equal again
like i was stunned when i was analyzing
this game like how many mistakes from
both ends
just because of time travel right now uh
queen f6 suddenly
is spoiling all the advantage because
other queen a4
is i'm not clear how what what is
actually doing
yes you can play move g5 but it doesn't
it's what happened in the game of g6 but
it doesn't
uh lead anywhere because of queen a7 and
now queen a6 tried to trade the queen
the quarter trade the queens
and basically uh what happens is that
white is
running short on the tempe uh relative
to the
line that i would we just discussed
after you know queen d7
g5 where exactly same thing happens but
already
after queen a4 points on g6 and
[Music]
what is right now simply winning so
uh coming back to the game the king of
eight uh queen of six
happened it was a big mistake obviously
uh and
but right now ray had only one move that
was winning and
in time trouble it's simply impossible
to play assassin with queen c2
queen c2 uh defense a4 pawn uh
attacks the c4 bishop it's kind of like
usually in time travel such moves are
out of radar because you want to
look for something on the king's side
and try to you know create some attack
or tactical structural ideas
instead you just have to instead quit
just consolidating move
that defends the pawn and backwards if
you don't look for such moves when
you're in time trouble
at least so after queen that queen d4
uh also such moves like queen c2 allows
checks from this side and you need to
see queen f2
and sometimes it may go you can
search move as queen of two maybe out of
radar so after queen g4
just queen uh c5 and for instance rookie
free
and again as you can guys can see rook
queen is coming back to this diagonal
with
on this diagonal and covers
you know all the entry points on the on
desire on this diagonal
that you know we can this kink can ever
get checked
and after e3 for instance next move
with the idea of preparing let's say
king h2 maybe rook
g3 or h3 g3 the game is still
just you know decided like why simply of
course roger is the only winning move
if i was also winning there are many
many winning moves here for white
i thought roger was one of the most
instructive ones
however the guy happened queen f6 after
queen takes a4
g5 queen a7 king h1 suddenly queen a6
and uh g6 is not coming through
so uh what to do like
why if the queens are traded the game is
just drawn immediately
um so right play move queen d4
and this is a very very strong move by
ray so
probably play also in time pressure but
finally the queen comes back to the
center
and to this long diagonal or like
also this like most most importantly
this diagonal
covers all the you know possible checks
on on this diagonal
of the white king and after
uh and here this okay i should take this
from this arrow away
basically what happens is that in this
position
black pieces are still not coordinated
and it is uh
difficult to make a move for for black
especially in such time trouble that
probably both players were like
the game was extremely complicated
obviously and this move
number already 43 and uh
considering the number of mistakes from
both sides both i had to be in big big
time trouble
so right now uh hikaru
messed up by playing bishop d3 and
again this seemingly is very natural
because you want to you know blockade
this g6 pawn somehow
and put some blockade like bishop g6 or
something like this
and try to hold somehow however
this move simply loses and we'll see why
in a moment
instead which the movie was make holding
a draw is bishop b5 and this completely
absurd move that
i don't think it would out anyone would
cross anyone's mind
like it's totally engine like
move that you know it's pretty much over
the board especially in rapid just
it's impossible to find nearly like
i don't know it's hard to even
understand this move the point is though
that it covers
some lines e8 square and
the difference with bishop d3 after
bishop d3 this bishop is sometimes
under attack the queen has to let's say
stay on this diagonal
uh or like somehow keep defending this
difficulty should be defended
on bishop b5 after bishop b5 though this
queen has some
room to some some freedom has to can
move some
somewhere else let's say after okay one
we can play queen c6 the queen doesn't
have to be on this diagonal
and uh queen six also covers a8 square
so white drew cannot go there
uh so yeah like suddenly
black can can survive this out of
nowhere
bishop d3 after bishop will be however
rouge one suddenly the queen
uh has to go somewhere else to keep this
bishop defended
but this come this allows rook a8 and
there is lots of loads of checks
that white can do
and uh it is
yeah the repeated once and the king is
pretty much exposed
very exposed black's king but the
question is again how to proceed
and the the mistake right now
ray play queen c5 which is the move that
against police the win
as i said mutual mistakes from both
sides i mean mutual mistakes here
both players were probably in time
trouble as i said
queen c5 is a mistake because after
suddenly knight d6
everything is protected suddenly bishop
on the phrase protect knight c is
protected
queen on g6 every is calling both pieces
together
and with such inside this position
uh it is not easy to make progress
suddenly for white after rook h8
um okay if queen if i can
play for instance move like king d7
not easy to say not easy to say what
what's going on next
after aj trying to keep the you know h5
uh protected let's say queen f7
black wants to play something queen f1
look if
some analysis moves like this bishop g6
rook d4 queen e6
bishop before suddenly everything
somehow holds i don't know how
exactly holds but like hulk's queen
seven queen
queen c7 queen d7 it's it's crazy to
like to play like this but like
and to believe that it can hold but in
refuge it just does suddenly it's not
possible or easy for white to you know
uh
to break black's defense here instead he
carpet queen d6
and after this move the game was pretty
opposite over after k7 and we'll get
there in a moment
i would just would like to quickly show
why quincy what
what could do after instead of queen c5
and the wing was queen a7
and this is pretty much uh logical uh
because
queen a7 just keeps checking and
white black has no way to escape those
checks like let's say
not escape but like to cover from the
check let's say queen c5
allows knight d6 right and already is
there is some
coordination of black pieces after queen
e7 uh sorry queen a7
black's pieces are misplaced after
king's six let's say rook g8 the king
goes sort of for a stroll it was the
middle of the board queen b7 analyzed
queen d7 that's a king c3 win 7 king d4
queen f4 king d5
of course there are lots of
possibilities for both sides
right now as one of the example lines
queen e3 the point
in general i'm trying to say in this
line is that
both sides i mean white blocking is
under constant pressure is not let's say
safe somewhere
behind black pieces on g7 or somewhere
like this or like you know
on d6 that can be kind of like well
guarded with on d7 let's say
right now 97 is badly placed and king is
open this or is subject to all sort of
attacks from both sides
all sides like from here from there
maybe from here the knight goes
somewhere maybe black white consider
basically playing this
uh lots of lots of ideas for white and
essentially as i say if the engine is
already plus six four wide
so this can be so this should be
completely winning however over the
board it still
may not be super trivial but yeah
uh objectively white should be winning
uh
and the idea in general just why this is
winning what the third year or
the other one is not the difference in
the king
um position of black's king
here it's totally exposed and after
queen c596
uh yeah this position for instance it
can hide behind the knights very often
and that's the main main difference so
the game happened queen decision
probably just about to hit our blundered
seven and after this queen c8 and the
game is
pretty much already over after king e5
queen eight
king four queen f7 king g4 uh
queen f3 not only but
sufficient queen seven trading the the
queens
and there are two pawns and uh for an
exchange
uh material advantage for white and this
is totally winning
rouge g7 just securing the pawn bishop
b1 bringing the key right down to curve
strategies to bring the king forward
as exactly what ray does
rook c7 and finally nice tactical idea
converting to the pawn end game g6
bishop to hg6 through g7
after king f4 white wins due to the
opposition is actually actually the same
uh or very similar at least end game to
the one uh
we've seen earlier in wesley saw
against uh jeffrey zhang however in this
place i think was upon f5 runner spawn
g5 but equally winning
so yeah this was this was it for this
game and it was completely
crazy and lots of stuff was going on and
uh
i don't know what to say pretty much
like
what what i can say is that that
in time trouble and time pressure like
everyone makes mistakes
and even the best players in the world
so it does all those mistakes don't take
away any
of their strength so it's maybe for
people who sit like in front of the
computer it's easy to you know see that
here evaluation jumps because of this
and that
but let's say from human perspectives
perspective
lots of moves make sense over the board
when you play them it's just sometimes
you know
positions are so complex that they
require simply more time to
just say just jump into and to
understand what's going on
and um in rapid chess
even the best players uh make mistakes
so uh but nonetheless the game was
extremely interesting there were a lot
of
interesting ideas for both sides
attacking the defensive
uh for uh for white and black
and i think there was there was lots of
things to learn from in this game
one thing that i would like to do if i
have to think about the most important
thing to learn from this game
is the feeling sort of uh
for initiative and kind of like
constantly looking for dynamic options
for for
for both sides not not only when you're
attacking but also when you're defending
uh they as as the saying goes the best
defense is to attack so and
uh here very often the best defense for
hikar was
basically to attack uh
you know to try to look for counter
attack and um
so so yeah this this i can say this
nonetheless the game was very
interesting and
well played by both players who and
eventually
uh congrats to ray for for uh for
winning this game
so that's all from from me for today and
i'll see you guys next time thank you
you